these are a symbol of Hope and peace in
Ukraine and people around the world have
been using sunflowers to express
solidarity with ukrainians but in recent
weeks the sunflower has come to
represent something else too surging
food prices due to Russia's violent
Invasion here's why
sunflower oil is in all kinds of stuff
that you probably have in your kitchen
margarine Mayo pesto breads chips and so
much more the oil is popular because it
has a mild flavor and a high smoke point
it's made from sunflower seeds which
come from this part of the flower now
these are just decorative but the
national sunflower Association told me
that those big flowers you see in
sunflower fields can have one thousand
to two thousand sunflower seeds per head
sunflower oil producers remove the seeds
from their shells crush them and extract
the oil Ukraine normally accounts for
nearly half of the world's sunflower oil
exports according to research for
mintech but because of the war shipments
have ground to a halt Colonel a major
producer in Ukraine told me that until
the war is over there's very little
chance they'll even achieve 30 percent
of what they were exporting before the
war
now there's a global shortage of
sunflower oil and that has triggered a
domino effect my colleague Sabara
Chowdhury covers the consumer goods
industry for the Wall Street Journal she
says food companies have been scrambling
to find replacements for sunflower oil
like rapeseed oil also known as canola
it's interesting so sunflower oil is in
short supply but grape seed which is a
totally different oil is also now
running out and the prices of rapeseed
have actually gone up 72 percent
companies have also looked to other
cooking oils as substitutes sending the
prices of those oils surging too in
March prices of sunflower rapeseed soy
and palm oils hit record highs even the
price of olive oil which is generally
considered too expensive and Niche to
substitute for sunflower oil was up 15
percent from last year but just
substituting oils isn't that simple for
companies for example soy oil raises the
risk of allergies and concerns about
genetically modified ingredients you
have to sort of like create all these
new labels maybe get new regulatory
approval to say yes it's okay to book
these new products in it's a lot a lot
of twists and turns to all this as
cooking oils get more expensive food
companies are considering raising the
prices of their products if they haven't
done so already which parts of the world
will be affected the most everybody's
going to be impacted and what's really
tricky is it's hard to narrow this down
because there's such a knock-on effect
but that being said obviously places
where people's incomes are really
squeezed I think Emerging Markets
without a doubt in Turkey a sharp
increase in sunflower oil prices sparked
Panic buying in any Rock Street
protesters have called themselves the
revolution of the starving
keep in mind this cooking oil crunch
comes on top of food inflation that was
already high before the war and it's
playing out alongside a wheat shortage
since Russia and Ukraine aren't
exporting as much grain as they normally
do as demand for sunflower oil remains
High farmers in the U.S and in other
parts of the world are expected to plant
more sunflowers this year in the U.S the
planting season happens around May and
the national sunflower Association told
me it expects about a 20 increase in
plantings but whatever is grown here in
the U.S will only meet a fraction of
global demand and experts say there
simply isn't enough sunflower oil in the
world to make up for the shortfall
caused by the war in Ukraine while the
sunflower represents hope and peace in
Ukraine the Russian government has been
using a black and orange striped Z to
represent pro-war sentiment in Russia
check out this video to learn more about
that and if you like this piece hit the
like button and subscribe to the channel
for more stories like this I'll see you
next time